tenemos tres rectas y debemos determinar
cuáles de ellas son paralelas la recta a
y no puede ser vale la a sí misma tics
el palais la otra la recta cuya ecuación
está dada por ye igual a tres cuartos de
x menos cuatro la recta b
la recta de cuya ecuación está dada por
4 y menos 20 igual a menos 3x y
finalmente la recta c cuya ecuación está
dada por menos 3 x + 4 y igual a 40 para
verificar si alguna de estas rectas es
paralela a alguna de las otras tenemos
que comparar sus pendientes si
cualesquiera estas dos rectas tienen la
misma pendiente y ya que son distintas
rectas pues varía su ordenada al origen
entonces las rectas son paralelas para
la recta es muy fácil identificar su
pendiente pues está en forma pendiente
ordenada mx más ve así es que la
pendiente es igual a tres cuartos
mientras que la ordenada al origen que
es irrelevante para determinar rectas
paralelas es igual a menos 4 veamos cuál
es la pendiente para las otras rectas
esta recta no está en ninguna de las
formas conocidas no está en la forma
punto pendiente ni en la forma pendiente
ordenada por lo que tenemos que
manipular la ecuación para encontrar el
valor de la pendiente así es que vamos a
despejar bien vamos a despejar y para
eso sumamos 20 a ambos lados de la
ecuación que nos resulta entonces
del lado izquierdo menos 20 se cancela
con 20 por lo cual nos queda 4 y es
igual a menos 3 x + 20 dividido ahora
entre 4 ambos lados de la ecuación
dividido entre 4 a ambos lados de la
ecuación del lado izquierdo tenemos
estos 4 se cancelan nos da igual a menos
tres cuartos menos tres cuartos de x más
veinte cuartos que es igual a cinco la
ecuación ya está en la forma pendiente
ordenada por lo cual la pendiente es
igual a menos tres cuartos es diferente
que la de esta recta esto es menos tres
cuartos
y esta es tres cuartos así es que estas
rectas no son paralelas vayamos ahora a
la recta c está en la forma general
vamos a despejar qué entonces sumamos 3x
ambos lados de la ecuación sumamos 3x
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
izquierdo se cancelan las 3x nos queda 4
y es igual a 3 x + 40 o 40 más 3x es
exactamente lo mismo
vamos a dividir ambos lados entre 4
dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación
entre 4 del lado izquierdo que me queda
que es igual a tres cuartos de x tres
cuartos de x + 10 así es que para esta
recta la pendiente es igual a tres
cuartos y de paso determinamos que la
ordenada al origen es igual a 10 así es
que esta recta y esta recta son
paralelas tienen la misma pendiente que
es igual a tres cuartos son rectas
distintas pues la ordenada al origen es
distinta así es que la recta se y la
recta a son paralelas mientras que la
recta b no es paralela a ninguna de las
otras dos